you
the taken king is the next major chapter
in the destiny saga involves Oryx an
ancient hive king born from darkness and
he's come to the system with a single
goal in mind revenge son
there's a cabal based on phobos and
something's going on there we're not
quite sure and the Vanguard have sent
you to go investigate we've intercepted
a cabal distress signal on Phobos be
ready for anything
it's clear that kawal are not leading an
invasion but they're actually fleeing
from an enemy
oryx is here
and he's brought with them an evil army
of corrupted taken
combatants that have been ripped out of
our dimension
and sit back with new powers new
abilities you're going to challenge
players in new ways
you might be fighting against the Cabal
or hive and all of a sudden Forks drops
his troops in there and now you're
fighting a completely different set of
enemies
we want the tones impress urgency on you
we want you to start to feel like wow
this oryx he's here he's coming for me
and my friends and we have to stop it
cuz we want to wear his like a hat like
we would we wanted to do something that
retained elements of where the taken
came from but that unified them so
they've got like this supernatural flame
that's burning them from the inside and
because we wanted to communicate their
will being a race they tend to have
jitter in their animations and sort of a
tortured look to them
one of the design goals for the taken
was to make the alien races of Destiny
feel even more a
in the taken King you're going to go to
a new destination for exist dreadknot
his massive castle in the sky and you're
gonna have to explore it he would have
to track him down and find him it's like
a giant evil mausoleum there are puzzles
that at first you might not discover you
might not even understand they've got
prisons summoning pits they've got
ceremony and all those things are
combined in this giant floating fortress
the place is ancient it's millions of
years old and it's filled with looting
the city in the vanguard realized we're
not powerful enough to stop Oryx
we need to rediscover some of the lost
art of our forebears and so you've sent
off on the quest to discover these
former powers Guardians use that we have
three new subclasses The Night Stalker
the storm caller and the Sun bring the
Night Stalker gives the hunter a support
class that he doesn't have right now and
allows him to bind his enemies with a
void powered boner
he brings that bow back hits a guy
charges up and then goes out captures
the other guys instead of just like a
one-off like it's just a little bit more
exciting
the Warlock is the storm caller involves
calling for the storm of arc energy to
decimate your your enemies
gets down in Crouch pose and then blasts
out lightning strikes him he becomes
infused with that energy and now you're
just roaming the mat like an electric
god
the Titans some breakers are solar
tightening subclass you get to wheel
that's awesome flaming hammer
Crouch's down like creates that hammer
and then just throws it we wanted it to
feel like any time you come around the
corner and you see that guy you just
want to run
mayhem as a brand new competitive mode
in a crucible we wanted to see what
happened when we let ability energy
recharge and super energy recharge
really quickly how will you fare against
utter chaos Guardians
and that's where the name mayhem comes
from so it's essentially team deathmatch
but everything is turned up to 11
rift is Destiny's answer to capture the
flag style objective mode
your team has to grab this far and then
bring it to the enemy teams rift
there's two ways you can do it you can
go in for words and do the traditional
mm don't get right in you can also
backflip dunk which Nets you extra
points for style
if the enemy team grabbed it you have
the [ __ ] you then have to defend your
point and make sure they don't bring the
spark into your wrist
destiny is a persistent world that is
constantly moving forward and this fall
with the taken king it's taking a major
to leave there's a new villain new
places to go new enemies their new
subclasses there's all new exotics new
public events new patrols everything
we're doing amazing stuff with weapons
that were not even ready to talk about
yet
we have new progress for your characters
your guardians are going to become more
powerful than they've ever been and yes
we're gonna have a whole bunch of new
strikes and we have listened like we
know Val's talk is too much house get it
we have rooms that begin to feel like
bosses there like a tip in the next
direction that we're gonna go
and the team has been hard at work
crafting our next big raid
we're on the forms we're reading reddit
we're reading yo gabba seeing what
people like what they don't like want
them to see like speculative posts about
what's where and what's how and how does
this all work is there an extra chest in
the vault of glass like I'll never tell
those are the sorts of narratives that
we want to tell as we begin here too and
yea year two begins with destiny the
taken King
get the complete destiny adventure that
taken King legendary edition
you